bonjour
il va
les deux jean claude
à jean claude michaux
ses contemporains il est l'auteur de
plusieurs livres sur le sujet du
libéralisme
et si le nom de michéa ne vous dira
peut-être rien c'est pour une raison
aussi simple que surprenante
qui est que michéa n'a jamais cherché à
être connu
cher est un auteur pour le moins
atypique
car voilà un homme qui a publié une
douzaine de livres mais qui
parallèlement déclare sans rougir qu'il
a toujours détesté écrire
son premier ouvrage a été publié alors
qu'il avait déjà 45 ans ce qui
correspond à un âge plus qu'avancé pour
un auteur
et cette première publication n'était
pas tendu à sa volonté qu'à celle de son
ami alain martin fondateur des éditions
climats qui avait besoin de texte a
publié pour lancer sa maison d'édition
d'une certaine manière on peut dire que
c'est malgré lui que mischa est devenu
écrivain
car comme il le dit si bien
s'il a continué à écrire des livres par
la suite
c'était à chaque fois le pistolet de
l'amitié sur la tempe
même michel à a toujours refusé de
passer à la télévision
il n'accorde que très peu d'entretien à
la radio et dans la presse écrite
préférant selon ses propres mots le
plaisir des plages montpelliéraine et
des soirées entre amis aux apparitions
médiatiques et aux dîners mondains
chehat s'est toujours montré lucide
quant aux limites voire aux dangers de
la célébrité médiatique étant conscient
que la pensée médiatique répond d'abord
à la logique du spectacle et que le
spectacle s'accommode mal de la pensée
complexe et profonde
de ce qu'on appellera une pensée
dialectique
bien montrer noam chomsky la télévision
n'est pas le lieu de la pensée
dialectique
elle n'est pas le lieu de la pensée qui
se déploie dans le temps elle est au
contraire le lieu de la pensée binaire
[Musique]
c'est à dire de la pensée immédiatement
classable
immédiatement catégorisables
de la pensée reposant sur des schémas
intellectuelle et mentaux auquel nous
sommes habitués
et qui à force d'être reproduit
aboutissent à ce qu'on pourrait appeler
une pensée conditionné
pensez de mischa est le contraire d'une
pensée conditionné
c'est précisément parce qu'elle ébranle
totalement les repères sur lesquels nous
avons l'habitude de faire reposer nos
raisonnements et plus particulièrement
nos raisonnements politiques
lorsqu'on entend parler dans les médias
de la gauche et de la droite
ou de conservateurs et de progressistes
ces catégories conceptuelles renvoi
instantanément dans notre esprit à des
images familières
tellement familières que nous ne les
questions n'ont même plus
c'est la raison pour laquelle la plupart
des débats politiques nous semble
finalement assez stérile
parce que nous n'y apprenons rien de
nouveau et parce que chacun préférera
défendre un discours que des livres est
une parole
l'homme de droite reprochera à l'homme
de gauche d'être de gauche
l'homme de gauche reprochera à l'homme
de droite d'être de droite
et finalement c'est un peu ça le
présupposé tacite de tout débat
politique
un affrontement de clan où chacun prêche
pour sa paroisse
et parce que nous avons besoin de
repères pour pouvoir nous définir
idéologiquement de même que nous
souhaitons que l'autre soit lui aussi
définissable et plaçables sur le damier
politique
nous acceptons ces catégories
nous les revendiquons même
et ce faisant nous sombrons dans une
sclérose de la pensée
dans une pensée mécanique ou toute idée
un peu original se verra balayé
ce sont précisément ces catégories que
mischa entend remettre en cause
à travers une réflexion extrêmement
stimulante que je vous invite à
découvrir le temps de cet épisode
et qui risque fort de mettre à mal vos
propres repères idéologiques et votre
manière habituelle de concevoir la
marche de notre monde
l'entrée dans le vif de la pensée de
michel je voudrais prendre le temps
d'ajouter quelques mots sur l'homme
afin d'éclairer ne serait ce que
partiellement le sens de sa démarche
il est né à paris en 1950 de parents
résistants communistes il grandi dans un
quartier populaire du 12e arrondissement
et il adhère très tôt à l'idéal
communiste de ses parents des parents
qu'il qualifiera dans une formule que
j'aime beaucoup de stalinien ouvert
aujourd'hui l'adjectif stalinien
comporte une charge très péjorative
ce que le jeune jean claude constate lui
ces quatre communistes chez les michéa
c'est d'abord incarné certaines valeurs
c'est être fier d'être un travailleur
c'est ne pas avoir la réussite sociale
comme le but ultime de la vie
c'est respecter le sens de l'effort
pratique et la générosité
et avoir l'esprit de convivialité
et c'est ce qui fait que même après
avoir rompu avec le communisme
mischa conservera toute sa vie un
attachement profond à ses origines
populaires et à l'idéal d'égalité qui
lui correspond
fin michéa passe le plus clair de son
temps libre à lire les livres de la
bibliothèque familiale
il s'initie très tôt à la philosophie
puisque à l'âge de 14 ans il y
matérialisme et empire you criticisme un
ouvrage de lénine particulièrement
difficile que le père du jeune jean
claude avait rangé tout en haut de la
bibliothèque
comme pour mieux lui en interdire
l'accès et ce afin d'éveiller chez son
fils le goût de la lecture et des idées
après son bac mischa étudie la
philosophie à la sorbonne en plein mai
il obtient son agrégation de philosophie
en 1972 il est alors le plus jeune
agrégé de france puis il part
s'installer dans le sud de la france
où il exercera pendant trente ans comme
professeur de philosophie au lycée
joffre
à ce propos il est important de signaler
que michéa a toujours refusé les offres
qui lui ont été faites d'obtenir un
poste à l'université
parce que disait-il enseigné la
philosophie à de futurs philosophe c'est
comme faire du pain pour des boulangers
ça n'a pas grand intérêt
et si ce choix de carrière de michel
hamm par est révélateur le fait qu'ils
aient choisi de vivre sous les néons
d'une salle de classe plutôt que sous la
lumière des projecteurs
c'est parce qu'un tel choix reflète
assez bien
l'engagement qui sera le sien tout au
long de sa vie
à savoir celui d'un démocrate radical
d'un démocrate qui ne s'estiment pas au
dessus des autres
pour achever cette brève présentation de
l'homme ajoutons que michel ne s'est
jamais considéré comme un militant
politique
trop épicuriens pour cela dira-t-il
et que la seule dénomination qu'il
consentira à endosser c'est celle de
socialiste au sens que ce terme pouvait
avoir jusqu'à la fin du 19e siècle
et vous verrez que cette précision aura
son importance dans la suite de cet
épisode
maintenant à l'exposé de la thèse de
michel
une thèse dont michel lui-même est
parfaitement conscient qu'elle paraîtra
saugrenue pour ne pas dire totalement
invraisemblable
cette thèse peut se résumer de la
manière suivante
la gauche et la droite constituent deux
forces politiques qui oeuvre toutes deux
au déploiement d'un seul et même projet
le projet libéral
autre manière
le dire
opinion généralement répandue le
libéralisme sociétale de la gauche et le
libéralisme économique de la droite ne
sont pas adversaires mais
complémentaires
bon alors là je devine qu'il y à déjà
parmi vous des auditeurs contrarié
des auditeurs contrarié qui protesteront
contre cette thèse qu'ils trouveront au
mieux amusante au pire scandaleuse
alors d'où viendront les protestations
or des partisans de la gauche
des partisans de la gauche qui
s'offusquent auront qu'on puisse dire
que la gauche et libéral
puisque comme chacun sait la gauche
c'est précisément ce qui s'oppose au
libéralisme
à gauche c'est la lutte des classes
la gauche c'est la défense des milieux
populaires
dire que la gauche et libéral ce serait
commettre un grave contresens historique
un joueur politique
mais les partisans de la gauche ne
seront pas les seuls à trouver la thèse
de michéa scandaleuse puisque ceux qui
se reconnaissent dans la droite auront
eux aussi leur mot à dire
libéralisme étant dans notre esprit le
projet économique de la droite
comment peut-on oser dire que la gauche
partage ce projet
alors même qu'elle ne cesse d'en appeler
à toujours plus de charges pour les
entreprises a toujours plus d'impôts et
à toujours plus de réglementation
et enfin la troisième catégorie
d'objection viendra de ceux qui
condamneront ce qui leur apparaît très
ici comme un discours de type populiste
un discours de stigmatisation de la
classe politique dans son ensemble
et qui ne peut aboutir qu'à une
dangereuse confusion dans les esprits
n'est ce pas la tâche du philosophe de
combattre ce genre d' amalgame
et bien si vous vous reconnaissez dans
l'une ou l'autre de ces catégories
d'objection et que vous estimez que
michéa à tort de faire de la gauche et
de la droite
les deux versants d'une seule et même
logique libérale
accrochez-vous bien parce que vous
n'êtes pas au bout de vos peines
shia va encore plus loin
puisqu'il ne dit pas seulement que la
gauche et la droite travaillent main
dans la main au déploiement du
libéralisme dans nos sociétés
il affirme également que la gauche en
est la matrice originelle
et le grand intérêt de l'argumentation
de michéa
c'est qu'elle va s'appuyer non pas sur
des opinions
mais sur des concepts que chacun d'entre
nous va pouvoir comprendre et placé sous
la lentille de son esprit critique
est ce que nous allons voir maintenant
pour comprendre
thèse de niche hermes
obligatoire va être de remonter aux
origines du clivage gauche droite
source de tous les malentendus
what remonte à la révolution de 1789
qui a vu l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
nationale se scinder en deux groupes
antagonistes
la gauche qui regroupait les partisans
de la révolution
et la droite
qui fédérait les contre révolutionnaires
autrement dit les partisans de l'ancien
régime
fini c'est donc par sa volonté de rompre
avec l'ordre ancien avec l'ordre moral
traditionnel et conservateur
tandis que la droite la réaction
entendait rétablir l'ordre moral et
religieux qui légitimait le pouvoir
royal
quand les maîtres mots de la droite
était en ordre moral et traditions les
maîtres mots de la gauche était raison
progrès et mouvements
est ce qu'il faut d'ores et déjà noter
ici c'est que ce qu'on appellera plus
tard le socialisme c'est à dire le
projet de défense politiques et
économiques de la classe travailleuse
est alors parfaitement étranger à ce
clivage
au xviiie siècle le socialisme comme
force politique n'existe pas
il ya une confusion qui s'est propagée
dans nos esprits
sans doute à cause de quelques cours
d'histoire mal digéré qui consiste à
croire que la gauche révolutionnaire
devrait à la défense des travailleurs et
du prolétariat
sauf qu'à l'époque le prolétariat
n'existait pas
assimiler la gauche au socialisme c'est
comme être un anachronisme sur la
naissance du socialisme qui est d'abord
lié au contexte de la révolution
industrielle au 19e siècle
et si le tiers état était bel et bien
constitué à la fois de la paysannerie et
de la bourgeoisie
dans les faits les députés du tiers état
appartenait à la bourgeoisie
et non à la paysannerie
le sédiment intellectuelle de la
révolution française ce n'est pas le
manifeste du parti communiste
c'est la philosophie des lumières
philosophie des lumières c'est à dire
montesquieu diderot voltaire des auteurs
dont les oeuvres sont encore étudié au
lycée
pensez par exemple à candide de voltaire
aux lettres persanes de montesquieu
et qu'est ce qui relie ces oeuvres
c'est l'importance centrale accordée à
l'idéal de liberté
l'idéal de liberté de progrès de
tolérance mais aussi à la notion
d'individu l'individu étant considérés
comme porteurs de droits naturels et
sacré
or lorsque quand tu entreprends de
définir l'esprit des lumières il écrit
que les lumières correspondent à la
sortie de l'homme hors de l'état de
tutelle
et siècle l'humanité a vécu sous tutelle
sous la tutelle d'un ordre imposé
et désormais
c'est aux individus de devenir leur
propre m
donc comprendre les sens philosophique
de la gauche c'est comprendre que la
gauche est d'abord porté par une
dynamique d'émancipation vis-à-vis de
toutes les structures normative
structure normatif qui sont conçues
comme autant de freins à la liberté
naturelle de l'être humain
c'est ça le maître mot de la gauche
originel
liberté
la liberté contre la tyrannie la
tolérance contre le fanatisme
la raison le progrès contre
l'obscurantisme la tradition
et si un démocrate ne peut voir que d'un
oeil bienveillant la promotion de tels
idéaux
le fait est que définir la gauche comme
une force politique au service des
intérêts des travailleurs
c'est un contresens historique
non pas que le socialisme ne rejoigne
aucune des valeurs de la gauche mais
simplement que la gauche et le
socialisme constituent des programmes
philosophique distincts
radicalement distincts
et c'est sur ce malentendu originel sur
cette confusion tragique entre gauche et
socialisme que prospère encore la
croyance collective selon laquelle être
de gauche c'est défendre les
travailleurs
la révolution française n'a pas accouché
de la déclaration des droits du
travailleur
elle a accouché de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen
et ce n'est pas du tout la même chose
marc se moquer du concept de droits de
l'homme les rebaptisant droits de
l'homme bourgeois c'était justement pour
signaler que lorsque la gauche défendez
les droits de l'homme elles défendent lé
droit abstrait de l'homme abstrait
delhomme abstrait c'est à dire abstrait
de ces conditions matérielles
d'existence
séparée de ses conditions matérielles
ce qualifier les droits de l'homme de
droits formels parce qu'en l'absence des
moyens matériels d'exercer un quelconque
droit
ce droit n'est qu'une coquille vide
vous avez beau avoir le droit d'être
heureux riche et en bonne santé
ce droit n'en devient pas pour autant
une réalité concrète
le droit est toujours extrait car le
droit ne se pose pas la question des
conditions de sa réalisation
que vaut le droit à la liberté de celui
qui n'a d'autre choix que de vendre sa
force de travail
que vaut le droit à l'égalité de celui
qui se situe tout en bas de la chaîne de
production
lorsque les droits de l'homme proclame
le droit naturel et inaliénable à la
propriété que vaut ce droit pour celui
qui n'a d'autres propriétés que sa vie
parce qu'à partir du moment où on
célèbre les droits de l'homme et du
citoyen on célèbre en réalité les droits
de ceux qui se trouvent en situation
matérielle de revendiquer de tels droits
c'est à dire de la bourgeoisie
comment interpréter le fait que le droit
de propriété soient définis dans la
déclaration des droits de l'homme comme
un droit inaliénable et sacré dans un
contexte socio économique où la
propriété ne pouvait être qu'un
privilège bourgeois
et si ce discours vous paraît choquant
demandez vous s'il n'est pas plus
choquant qu'une civilisation inscrivent
la propriété comme un droit naturel de
l'être humain et qu'on considère qu'un
tel droit aurait quelque chose à voir
avec le socialisme
mais mme rousseau se moquera du concept
de propriété en écrivant que le premier
qui eut l'idée de clôturer un terrain et
de dire ceci est à moi trouve à des gens
assez simple d'esprit pour le croire
et c'est dans ce quiproquo historique
dans cette identification frauduleuse de
l'idéal des lumières au socialisme que
s'enracine la mythologie moderne qui
consiste à voir dans la gauche le porte
étendard des intérêts du peuple alors
qu'elle ne fut en réalité que le porte
étendard des intérêts de la bourgeoisie
c'est ça la source du grand malentendu
ce n'est pas le socialisme
mischa est tout
chang en démystifiant ainsi la gauche
des lumières
il s'expose aux invectives foudroyante
de tous ceux qui verront dans sa
critique le signe d'une sympathie pour
la droite réactionnaire
c'est l'effet le plus commun de la
pensée binaire que j'évoquais au début
de cet épisode
une pensée binaire qui consiste à dire
que si on critique la gauche c'est qu'on
soutient la droite
chance qu'en prononçant cette phrase le
réflexe intellectuelle de beaucoup
d'auditeurs sera de se dire
bah oui
forcément
ils on critique la gauche
soutient la droite
il est d'ailleurs fréquent que michéa
soit qualifié de penseurs réactionnaire
parce qu'ils n'ont pas compris la
différence entre gauche et socialisme et
qui veulent absolument faire rentrer
toute pensée qui leur échappe
dans leur système de classification dont
ils ne voient même pas qu'il est
fondamentalement bancal
le propre d'une pensée binaire
c'est que tout ce qu'elle exclue elle
inclut dans son opposition
le propre d'une pensée binaire
c'est qu'elle refuse d'appuyer sur le
bouton pause pour vérifier pour ne
serait ce qu'envisager qu'il y ait dans
ses éléments constitutifs une
incohérence qui ne peut être résolu
qu'en sortant d'elle même
michéa insiste beaucoup sur la dimension
psychologique de nos opinions politiques
besoin de nous définir comme de gauche
ou comme de droite résulte moins d'une
conviction acquise par l'examen critique
que d'une nécessité de s'identifier à
des repères que nous estimons valorisons
il est psychologiquement valorisant de
se dire qu'on défend la cause des
faibles et des opprimés
et si on définit comme de gauche le fait
de défendre la cause des faibles et des
opprimés
tant pis si cette dénomination ne
correspond pas à la réalité d'une telle
cause
tant pis si des incohérences logiques
apparaissent entre ce qu'on promeut et
les conséquences de ce qu'on promeut
l'essentiel est temps qu'on puisse
continuer à se dire du côté du bien
philosophique de la gauche le signe
d'une sympathie pour la droite
c'est ça la pensée binaire
le rétablissement conceptuelle de la
distinction entre gauche et socialisme
la marque d'une volonté de retour à
l'ordre moral
c'est ça la pensée binaire
car à aucun moment ne pénètre dans une
pensée binaire l'éventualité qu'une
telle critique est en fait pour vertu de
repositionner correctement le problème
et que c'est en repositionnant
correctement le problème qu'on se donne
les moyens de le résoudre
s'affubler d'un adjectif symboliquement
gratifiant se déclarer progressiste ou
se dire en lutte contre les forces
réactionnaires
c'est moins se donner les moyens de son
combat que fermer les yeux pour
s'imaginer le remporter
au xviie siècle
l'europe est dévasté par 200 ans de
guerres de religion
des paysans en allemagne
soulèvement protestants en écosse la
guerre de la france contre le royaume
d'espagne
quand obs décrit l'état de nature comme
l'état de la guerre de tous contre tous
quand il écrit que l'homme est un loup
pour l'homme et que la nature humaine
est fondamentalement violente
il a évidemment à l'esprit l'horreur des
conflits d'intérêts d'un qui ont
ensanglanté son siècle
sortir de ce traumatisme des guerres
civiles idéologique que le problème
politique va prendre une forme inédite
au regard de l'histoire
en effet le problème qui va se poser au
théoricien politique ne sera plus de
savoir comment guider l'humanité vers le
bien
puisque c'est au nom du bien que les
hommes prennent les armes et ça ça signe
le problème va devenir comment faire en
sorte que les membres d'une société
cohabitent de façon pacifique
la conception moderne du problème
politique est donc indissociable de ce
contexte de violence idéologique et
religieuse
cher
si on ne prend pas en compte cette
donnée anthropologique ce constat du
caractère destructeur de la religion et
des idéologies en général on passe à
côté d'un élément central dans la
constitution de l'imaginaire politique
moderne
l'antiquité la plupart des sociétés
européennes étaient fondées sur un ordre
moral ou religieux
c'est à dire sur une certaine conception
du bien
de la cité juste de platon à la
communauté divine de saint thomas
d'aquin aucune théorie politique n'est
envisagée à un modèle de société qui ne
soit pas orientée vers le bien
rendre la renaissance avec machiavel
pour voir se déployer le premier modèle
politique de l'histoire qu'ils ne soient
plus fondés sur cette idée du bien
le prince de machiavel n'est plus celui
qui se soucie de sauver les âmes
il n'est plus celui qui cherche à ce que
les hommes obéissent à la loi divine ou
à un bien transcendant
il devient celui qui se soucie
uniquement de la stabilité de l'état
en d'autres termes ce que va initier
machiavel c'est une dissociation de la
politique et de la morale
la politique n'est plus conçu comme
l'art de faire advenir le bien sur terre
elle devient l'art d'administrer la
coexistence entre les membres d'une
société
et ce qui fait que machiavel opérer ce
changement de paradigme cette
transformation du rôle de l'état
politique c'est la conviction que la
réalité humaine
autrement dit que le monde de l'ici bas
ne pouvait être rigide que par les lois
de l'ici bas
or ici bas
ce n'est pas le bien qui règne
humaine
et vouloir faire descendre les lois
divines sur terre
vouloir que les hommes cessent de se
comporter en homme
c'est un projet 20
plutôt que d'espérer inutilement des
sommes qu'ils se comportent de manière
vertueuse la recommandation de machiavel
sera de dire qu'il faut prendre la
nature humaine telle qu'elle est
c'est à dire violente à vide borné
tourné vers sa propre satisfaction est
incapable de vertu au fond que ce
avec machiavel au xvième siècle ou avec
hops au 17e le constat qui est fait est
le même
celui d'une nature humaine
fondamentalement mauvaise
ce désespoir des penseurs politiques
quant à la nature humaine va déboucher
sur ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
approche pragmatique
le pragmatisme politique
la volonté d'apporter une solution
réaliste plutôt qu aux pistes au
problème de la coexistence entre les
hommes
parce qu'une fois qu'on a dit que les
hommes étaient incurablement mauvais
une fois qu'on a dit qu'il était
impossible de guider les hommes vers le
bien sans qu'ils s'entre déchirent
il faut bien malgré tout apporter une
réponse au problème
il faut bien faire avec cette nature
humaine qui refuse de se rectifier qui
semble même d'autant plus hargneuse et
meurtrière qu'on lui impose d'être
vertueuse
c'est ce qui fait dire à machiavel cette
phrase qui résume absolument tout il
faut estimer comme un bien
le moindre mal
et ce n'est d'ailleurs pas un hasard si
mischa a emprunté cette formule comme
titre d'un de ses livres
l' empire du moindre mal
autrement dit lempire qu'ils renoncent
aux biens
l' empire qui prend acte de
l'impossibilité radical d'exiger des
hommes qui se comporte de manière
vertueuse
et donc pour la première fois dans
l'histoire les théoriciens politiques et
en l'occurrence les théoriciens
politiques des lumières vont imaginer ce
qu'aucun d'entre eux n'avait pu non
seulement l'audace mais même l'idée
d'imaginer à savoir un modèle de société
fondé sur la privatisation des valeurs
privatisation des valeurs autrement dit
suppression de toutes les autorités
morales censé définir édicté la voie du
bien
ya une expression pour décrire ce
principe une expression qu'il emprunte
au sociologue max weber
c'est ce qu'il appelle le principe de
neutralité axiologique
l'axiologie c'est la science des valeurs
morales la neutralité axiologique c'est
donc l'absence de tout parti pris sur la
question des valeurs morales
c'est le désengagement c'est le retrait
de toute idéologie morales ou
religieuses dans la vie privée des
individus
et ça il faut bien comprendre que c'est
quelque chose d'absolument
révolutionnaire
pour la première fois dans l'histoire
des sociétés on déclare que l'état n'a
pas à intervenir dans les options morale
et idéologique des individus qui
composent la société
disons le autrement
pour la première fois dans l'histoire
des sociétés la liberté individuelle
venait d'être institué comme norme
politiques et sociales
c'est la naissance de ce qu'on appelle
libéralisme politique
et si j'ai pris le temps tout à l'heure
de vous retracer l'histoire de la gauche
des lumières c'est parce que c'est la
gauche qui sera à l'avant-poste de ce
nouveau paradigme politique
la gauche du mouvement
la gauche du progrès
la gauche de la tolérance et du droit
individuel
et le combat de la gauche
révolutionnaire contre la droite
réactionnaire
c'était le combat pour l'affirmation des
droits individuels contre le fantôme de
l'absolutisme
donc quand la gauche contemporaine
milite pour l'augmentation des droits
individuels quand elle se fait un devoir
de lutter contre toutes les structures
traditionnelles qui entravent la liberté
des individus
elle ne fait que réaliser son projet
initial
le rejet par la gauche contemporaine de
tout ce qui a trait à la tradition au
conservatisme à la hiérarchie c'est la
traduction directe de sa répulsion
primordial à l'égard de tous les
systèmes normatifs
parce que qu'est-ce qu'un système
normatif sinon un ensemble de règles qui
s'imposent de manière arbitraire à la
volonté des individus
qu'est ce qu'un système normatif sinon
un ensemble de contraintes artificielles
qui réduisent nos libertés
une fois qu'on a compris ça une fois
qu'on a compris que le progressisme de
la gauche contemporaine n'est que la
forme moderne du libéralisme politique
de la gauche d origine alors tout prend
sens
toutes les pièces du puzzle s'assemblent
dès lors qu'on comprend que les sens
philosophique de la gauche c'est le
libéralisme
la première
alice mme le libéralisme politique
correspond au projet décrit précédemment
d'instaurer une société axiologiquement
neutre c'est-à-dire une société neutre
sur le plan des valeurs
la neutralité axiologique c'est le
principe qui garantit aux membres d'une
société de vivre selon leur propre
définition du bien et qui fait que
l'état ne saurait nous demander des
comptes
quant à nos choix de vie privée
la question qui surgit alors c'est de
savoir comment les membres d'une société
vont pouvoir cohabiter pacifiquement
si aucune autorité n'est là pour réguler
les comportements
seahawks était partisan de la solution
absolutiste
s'il estimait qu'il fallait un
gouvernement fort et autoritaire pour
faire régner l'ordre
c'est parce qu'il était conscient que le
fait de laisser les hommes livrés à eux
mêmes ne pouvait conduire à l'anarchie
d'ailleurs c'est exactement ce que
redoutaient les adversaires des lumières
liberté des individus mènent au chaos
social
et bien la solution trouvée par les
libéraux politique c'était qu'il
suffirait de limiter la liberté de
chacun de telle sorte qu'elles
n'empiètent pas sur celle d'autrui
autres termes le seul critère de
légitimité d'une action c'était qu'elle
ne nuise pas à la paix sociale
la l'origine du célèbre adage
liberté des uns s'arrête où commence
celle des autres
cette définition correspondant très
exactement à la définition libéral de la
liberté
on a tendance à répéter cette phrase
comme s'il s'agissait d'une définition
objective et universel de la liberté
mais en réalité pas du tout
un citoyen d'athènes jamais un
républicain florentin n'aurait songé à
définir la liberté ainsi
la définition de la liberté apparaissent
il fallait en effet deux prérequis
premièrement accepter l'idée que la
liberté était une affaire strictement
individuel
et deuxièmement accepter l'idée que la
liberté était indépendante de la morale
or ces deux prérequis
c'est le libéralisme qui les a instauré
concept de liberté la question qu'on
doit toujours se poser c'est de quelle
liberté parle-t-on
s'agit-il de la liberté du maître par
rapport à l'esclave
s'agit-il de la liberté comme autonomie
de la volonté
comme chez spinoza de la liberté comme
conscience des causes qui nous détermine
de quelle liberté parle-t-on
pour les libéraux les choses ont le
mérite d'être beaucoup plus simple
pour eux la liberté c'est tout
simplement le droit
le droit
formés ou pas ivy
en particulière du bonheur du bien ou du
vrai
la liberté ne consiste plus à
s'affranchir de ce qui nous déterminent
ou de ce qui nous a servi
la liberté devient le droit de jouir
paisiblement de son existence
pour qu'une telle liberté soit respecté
par les membres de la société
il suffisait de lui donner un cadre
juridique
juridique que la déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen précise dans
ses articles 4 et 5
je cite la liberté consiste à pouvoir
faire tout ce qui ne nuit pas à autrui
ainsi l'exercice des droits naturels de
chaque homme n'a de bornes que celles
qui assurent aux autres membres de la
société la jouissance de ces mêmes
droits
ces bornes ne peuvent être déterminées
que par la loi
la loi n'a le droit de défendre que les
actions nuisibles à la société tout ce
qui n'est pas défendu par la loi ne peut
être empêché et nul ne peut être
contraint à faire ce qu'elle n'ordonne
pas
voilà donc ce qui définit la liberté
d'un point de vue libéral
le droit de faire tout ce qui ne nuit
pas à autrui
philosophique c'est ce qu'on appelle une
définition négative de la liberté
définition négative au sens où on
définit la liberté non pas parce qu'elle
est mais parce qu'elle n'est pas
parce qu'ils s'y opposent
pour les libéraux la liberté n'est pas
un concept ayant un contenu propre
elle est un espace vide que les
individus pourront remplir comme bon
leur semble du moment que l'usagé qu'ils
en feront n'entre pas en contradiction
avec usage que feront les autres de leur
propre espace de liberté
remarqué une chose une chose
fondamentale c'est que d'un point de vue
libéral
la loi n'est pas un obstacle à la
liberté
la loi est au contraire l'instrument de
la liberté
la loi est l'instrument de la liberté
puisque la loi c'est ce qui empêche
autrui d'empiéter sur mon espace de
liberté
et quand la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen nous informe que
tout ce qui n'est pas interdit par la
loi est autorisée elle nous confirme qu
être libre c'est d'abord et avant tout
ne pas être contraint par la volonté
d'autrui
dont tout est cohérent tout se tient
le libéralisme politique c'est le refus
de toute contrainte à l'égard de nos
choix individuels et la loi c'est
l'instrument défensif qui me prémunit
contre l'intrusion d'autrui dans ma
sphère de libertés privées
parce qu'aucune autorité morale n'a la
légitimité
dictée aux individus leur comportement
privé la coexistence entre les individus
sera assurée par une instance neutre et
un personnel le droit
aussi pas de ce qui est moralement juste
ce souci de ce que la loi autorise
aurait prime
d'où cette phrase qu'on entend souvent
face à un reproche
j'ai le droit
comme si le droit devenait le seul et
unique critère d'appréciation d'un
comportement
la société libérale
c'est la société de la redéfinition du
mal
mal c'est désormais le préjudice
sur le plan
symbolique vous remarquerez que le
tribunal est une sorte d'église moderne
c'est un établissement simili religieux
on pénètre à l'intérieur d'un tribunal
sans une atmosphère de solennité
les plafonds sont démesurément haut
comme pour nous rappeler à quel point
nous sommes petits
les avocats portent la robe
comme les prêtres porte la soutane
le marteau du juge a remplacé le
crucifix
giner symbolique du droit c'est la
transposition exacte de celui de la
religion
tribunal
c'est le temple du droit
c'était ont vu diminuer le caractère
sacré de la religion
elles ont vu augmenter le caractère
sacré du droit
c'est ça qui s'est produit dans ce
passage de l'ancien modèle au modèle
libéral
un transfert de sacralité
ce qui est sacré aujourd'hui ce n'est
plus le sens métaphysique de la vie sur
terre
ce sont nos droits
duo barreaux comme on entre et autrefois
dans les ordres
pour que justice soit faite
à ce stade de nos
son certains feront remarquer que si on
peut effectivement voir dans la gauche
l'initiatrice du libéralisme politique
il faut cependant opéré une distinction
entre ce libéralisme politique ou
libéralisme sociétale si on veut
utiliser une terminologie plus récentes
et le libéralisme économique
s'il est difficile pour la gauche
contemporaine d'assumer le mot de
libéralisme
un mot que nous associons spontanément à
la droite et qui par conséquent perturbe
grandement nos repères linguistique
il paraît en revanche totalement
illégitime d'assimiler la gauche au
libéralisme économique
ok pour le libéralisme sociétal mai
n'allons pas trop loin
et bien selon
or si
il faut aller plus loin
clément terre
il faut franchir 1
plémentaires non pas pour le plaisir de
franchir un pas supplémentaire mais
parce que c'est la nature même de la
philosophie libérale qui requiert que
nous franchissions ce pas
beaucoup trouveront déjà douloureux de
concéder que la gauche puisse avoir
quelque chose à voir avec le libéralisme
comme on l'a vu au début de cet épisode
nous fonctionnons sur des catégories
conceptuelles que nous n'acceptons pas
de remplacer quand bien même elle nous
empêcherait d'analyser correctement les
choses
or ce que montre michéa c'est que si on
peut effectivement distinguer la gauche
et la droite
le libéralisme lui
peut pas être coupé en deux
ermont le libéralisme est une doctrine
profondément unitaire
ce n'est qu'artificiellement et a
posteriori que nous différencions le
libéralisme sociétal du libéralisme
économique
mais en réalité il n'ya qu'un seul
libéralisme
et vous allez voir maintenant en quoi
les deux versions du libéralisme
économique et sociétal
sont en réalité indissociables
et que si on adhère alain on est
philosophiquement tenus d'adhérer à
l'autre
le projet libéral on l'a vu
tu es motivé par le désir de mettre un
terme au conflit idéologique qui
dressaient les individus les uns contre
les autres
sans que le genre humain périrait s'il
ne changeait sa manière d'être
la phrase est de rousseau les
théoriciens politiques abandonnent
progressivement leur ancien modèle de
société fondé sur la religion et la
morale et décide de fonder un ordre
politique conforme à la nature des
hommes
conforme à la nature des hommes
c'est-à-dire adapté à ce qu'ils sont
fondamentalement
à leur nature comportementale plutôt
qu'un idéal inatteignable
et c'est ce qui fait que si vous lisez
un traité de philosophie politique du
xviie ou xviiie siècle vous trouverez
presque toujours un chapitre qui traite
de la question de la nature de l'homme
[Musique]
une description de la nature de l'homme
finalement parce que pour savoir quel
est le modèle politique le plus
pertinent
il faut bien commencer par savoir ce que
sont les hommes et ceux qui les animent
c'est de la connaissance de la nature de
l'homme que peut découler une théorie
politique adaptée à la nature de l'homme
à cette époque il est encore trop tôt
pour parler de psychologie puisque sa
discipline ne verra le jour qu'au 19e
siècle
mais malgré tout on assiste déjà à une
première tentative d'identification des
lois du comportement humain
et cette volonté d'identifier les lois
du comportement humain il faut la
comprendre à la lumière du contexte
intellectuel de l'époque contexte
intellectuel marquée par le
développement des sciences
expérimentales de la nature
les philosophes sont fascinés par les
récentes découvertes en physique et en
astronomie et il voit dans ce progrès
scientifiques l'occasion de nourrir leur
réflexion philosophique
tendance de nos jours a opposé science
et philosophie mais jusqu'à récemment
ces deux disciplines tant d adam faire
qu'une
s'il n'y a rien de surprenant dans le
fait que des cartes et était à la fois
philosophe et physicien ou que pascal
était à la fois philosophe et
mathématicien c'est parce que toutes ces
disciplines avait pour finalité la
compréhension des mécanismes qui
régissent le monde
et donc les philosophes politiques vont
trouver dans le modèle scientifique une
sorte de modèle méthodologique ultime
modèle méthodologique ils vont pouvoir
transposer dans le domaine politique
ils vont se dire puisque tous les
phénomènes de l'univers sont régies par
des lois ce soit les lois du mouvement
des corps de newton ou les lois du
mouvement des planètes de kepler
il faut bien que le comportement humain
lui-même soit régi par des lois
c'est ce qu'on appelle le positivisme
lorsqu'on cherche à appliquer aux
questions humaines les méthodes
employées dans les sciences de la
matière
et d'ailleurs on parle aujourd'hui de
sciences politiques mais la première
approche scientifique de la question
politique c'est au libéralisme qu'on la
doit
et donc cette loi du comportement humain
cette loi du mouvement des corps sociaux
pourrait-on dire
les philosophes vont la trouver
ou en tout cas ils vont estimer l'avoir
trouvé
et c'est claude du comportement humain
quelle est elle c'est l'intérêt
pour les philosophes libéraux c'est
l'intérêt qui motive chacune de nos
actions
et celui qui formulera avec le plus de
maestria cette loi de l'intérêt
c'est le philosophe des lumières élevé
sus
qui dira je cite
si l'univers physique et soumis aux lois
du mouvement l'univers morale ne l'est
pas moins à celle de l'intérêt
voilà la réponse à la question la nature
humaine
l'intérêt
et c'est à dire l'égoïsme
l'intérêt c'est à dire le soin porté à
la satisfaction de nos désirs privé
et il faut bien comprendre que dans
cette conception des choses même les
actions les plus désintéressée en
apparence seront jugés comme étant le
résultat indirect de l'égoïsme
même le sens de la justice
même la capacité au sacrifice ou la
simple générosité seront vus comme des
manifestations des tournées de la
recherche de gloire ou du désir de
reconnaissance
c'est un peu la magie de cette théorie
de l'intérêt c'est que quoi qu'on fasse
nos actions seront toujours reconduite
en dernier ressort à des motivations
égoïstes
et si les hommes s'entretuent si
l'histoire humaine n'est rien d'autre
que l'histoire de la lutte entre les
hommes c'est parce que seuls leurs
désirs individuels préval
la guerre de tous contre tous peuvent
bien avoir comme prétexte la volonté de
faire régner le bien cette volonté elle
même n'est rien d'autre que la
traduction moralement acceptable de
notre égoïsme
les tyrans ont toujours une raison
morale de tyranniser
donc si les hommes sont égoïstes
faut trouver le moyen de convertir cet
égoïsme dans une forme pacifique
dans une forme qui rendent possible
malgré tout la coexistence entre les
individus
et quels moyens les libéraux vont ils
trouver pour convertir l'égoïsme des
hommes
la réponse est trouvé
ce sera le marché
le marché aux vertus pacifiante
c'est encadré par le droit
le marché comme moyen de satisfaire ses
pulsions égoïstes sans en passer par la
violence
et c'est pourquoi vous trouverez dans de
nombreux textes des lumières des
descriptions élogieuses de ce qu'on
appelait alors le doux commerce
la devise des libéraux c'est le commerce
adoucit les moeurs
c'est exactement ça le projet initial
des libéraux
l'investissement des moeurs
et pourquoi le commerce adoucit les
moeurs parce qu'il permet aux individus
de satisfaire leurs intérêts dans le
cadre de contrats mutuellement
avantageux
c'est ça le principe du contrat
chacune des parties il trouve son
bénéfice
le contrat est fondé sur le consentement
il a pour finalité le bénéfice
et en libérant son égoïsme dans le cadre
du marché les individus concours sans
même le vouloir à la prospérité
économique de la société
l'un des fondateurs du libéralisme
économique vous le connaissez déjà car
on a eu l'occasion d'en parler dans un
précédent épisode
c'est adam smith
smith et sa fameuse main invisible
la main visible symbolisant la
contribution de l'égoïsme individuel à
la richesse collective
en un mot
ce que dit adam smith sait que c'est en
laissant les agents économiques
travailler librement à la satisfaction
de leurs intérêts que la société a le
plus de chance de prospérer
invisible
l'idée absolument indispensable au
dispositif libéral que les intérêts
individuels s'harmonisent de telle sorte
qu'en laissant chacun à assouvir son
égoïsme
tout le monde y trouve son compte
libero que l'état doit se placer en
retrait de l'activité économique
que l'état ne doit pas intervenir dans
les choix économiques des individus
comme il ne doit pas intervenir dans
leurs choix moraux parce qu intervenir
dans les affaires économiques
c'est rompre l' harmonisation naturel
des intérêts
le pdg d'une grande entreprise en
appelle à plus d'ouverture
à plus de flexibilité et à moins de
réglementation
il en appelle aux pouvoirs de la main
invisible
une main invisible providentiel
quasi mystique
une sorte de puissance ordonnatrice
supra physique qui autorise mêmes qui
encouragent au nom du bonheur de la
société la libre satisfaction par chacun
de son égoïsme
et si le libéralisme économique
parachève le libéralisme politique
si les partisans du droit ne peuvent qu
adouber les partisans du marché c'est
précisément parce que le marché est
aussi un lieu de la liberté
partisan d'une liberté totale d'une
liberté non contrainte par des règles ou
par des systèmes de valeurs quels
arguments peut-on opposés au libéralisme
économique
au nom de quoi l'économie devrait elle
faire exception à l'idéal de liberté
considérer que les hommes sont libres
mais refuser la liberté économique
c'est une incohérence insoluble
bien sûr de nos jours on établit une
démarcation entre la liberté sociétale
la liberté dans le domaine des moeurs et
la liberté économique
comprendre que pour les premiers
libéraux
une telle distinction n'a pas de sens
sens tout simplement parce que la
liberté n'est pas quelque chose qu'on
pourrait couper et segmentée selon notre
bon vouloir
donc quand un libéral de gauche
c'est-à-dire un libéral sur le plan des
moeurs reproche un libéral de droite son
libéralisme économique
il lui reproche d'appliquer ses propres
principes
c'est assez gênant parce que dans notre
imaginaire symbolique nous aimons nous
représenter le libéral économique comme
un bourgeois réactionnaire incapable de
s'ouvrir à la liberté des moeurs moderne
mais c'est une erreur
une erreur dans la mesure où le
programme libéral prévoit que la liberté
individuelle concerne tout autant le
domaine des moeurs que le domaine
économique
et si ça vous paraît impensable si vous
pensez que c'est deux choses n'ont rien
à voir
il vous suffira de vous reporter aux
textes des libéraux du xviiie siècle
pour qui il allait de soi que ces deux
formes de liberté dans constitue en
réalité qu'une seule
suffire à lire les textes du très
libéral politique voltaire sur les
bienfaits du commerce et les plaisirs du
luxe
il vous suffira de lire les textes du
très libéral économique jeremy bentham
sur la défense des femmes et des
personnes homosexuelles
et alors vous verrez que les avancées du
marché n'ont pu être permise que par les
avancées des droits individuels de même
que les droits individuels ont toujours
été défendues par les partisans du
marché
andres que le libéralisme sociétale et
le libéralisme économique
sont que les deux faces de la même
médaille philosophique
comprendre que ces deux libéralismes
n'en constitue en réalité qu'un seul
se donner la possibilité de comprendre
en quoi l'opposition habituel entre la
gauche et la droite
est construite sur du sable
qui militerait pour l'extension des
libertés individuelles mais qui
voudraient entraver la liberté
économique
une droite qui en appellerait à un
marché libre
mais qui voudrait limiter les droits des
individus
mentalement et définitivement
la victoire
de l'analyse de michel
confronté à cette contradiction
en nous détournant les yeux
pour pouvoir mieux déploré les
conséquences de ce dont nous
cherry sont les causes
une contradiction que les développements
récents du libéralisme rendent de plus
en plus visible
de plus en plus éclatante
et c'est ce que nous verrons dans le
prochain épisode je vous remercie
[Musique]